Welcome to the DDPS seminar, everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have questions, you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your questions
so that we can address them in Q A session at
the end second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audience, therefore no classified
discussion is allowed, so please watch up.
And finally, the talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about it
now. Let me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr Aditi Krishna priyan,
who is an assistant professor at UC Berkeley,
where she is a member of Berkeley AI research
electrical engineering and computer science and
chemical engineering. Her research interests
include physics inspired machine learning
methods, geometric deep learning, inverse problems
and development of machine learning methods
informed by physical sciences applications,
including including molecular dynamics and
fluid mechanics. A former doe computational
science graduate fellow, she holds a PhD from
Stanford University and in and in 2022 2022
was the Louis Alvarez fellow in computing sciences
at Lawrence Berkeley National Laboratory. Today,
adity will talk about reaching numerical methods
and deep learning with physics constraint
differential solvers. I'm sure she's going to
give us a a fantastic talk. So please have a
high expectations. But before I pass the button
to Aditi, let me ask a you know, one questions as
usual, as a tradition of this DDPS center. So my
question is, for you, Aditi, is I happen to know
one of your hobby is translating your language
from one language to another language. How
my why is that hobby? That's my question. And what
kind of language do you usually translate from,
you know, to you know, what other languages?
Yes. Oh, yeah. I'm just generally interested in
different language families and bridges between
different language families, which tend to also
be informed by migration patterns. So looking
at completely different areas of the world and
seeing what the overlaps are in language families
is just a fun hobby to work on. It's gotten quite
interesting now, especially with some of
the llms and a lot of the improvement in in
translation. Oh, that's awesome. And that's kind
of related to your the title of your talk today,
reaching numerical methods and the deep
learning. Yes, so you like, you like to preach
store as stage is yours good? Yeah, thanks a
lot for the invitation and the introduction.
I was looking forward to giving this talk
because I think a lot of the themes here,
my impression is that they're going to overlap
a lot with the backgrounds of people in the
audience, which could be a mix of Applied
Math, machine learning, physics and so on.
And so this is going to just be a general
overview of what we can get from numerical
methods that we've known for a long time
and a lot of the more modern machinery and
deep learning that has obviously seen a lot of
success, especially in the last decade or so.
So a lot of this talk and a lot of the research
that we work on is really motivated by this big
question of machine learning potential
and modeling scientific systems, and more
specifically, a lot of these problems, I think,
come down to how well you can model spatial and
temporal behavior. So whether it's something like
modeling fluid dynamics or some type of weather
patterns, or even when you're looking at molecular
systems, how did the atoms move over time. These
are really all underlying represented by modeling
spatial and temporal behavior of those systems.
And I think there's so many applications where
this is actually a pretty challenging task,
where we have some really complex
phenomena, we want to really
understand all of the intricacies of that
spatiotemporal behavior, and by doing so,
I think this really unlocks a lot of insights
in many, many different fields of science.
So I'll briefly talk about
what I think are some of the
advantages that neural networks
can offer for physical modeling.
I think these can be a powerful
tool to assist us in this task,
while also keeping in mind some of the
limitations, or some of the things that
we have to just know a priori or account a
priori when we're developing these methods.
So the first point, and one of the big advantages
here is after you train a neural network,
when you actually go and test it or do
inference on new problems. This is quite
cheap because you've amortized
the computation during training.
And neural networks, as we as we've seen
time and time and again, they're really,
really good at approximating high dimensional
functions, and this starts to become really
nice when we're trying to solve these scientific
problems that are very high dimensional problems
and may have complicated solutions or
ways to get to complicated solutions
at the same time. I think there's
also some things to keep in mind,
particularly with neural networks in
the context of scientific computing.
So how do they actually compare to these current
mechanistic models or even experiments in a lab?
So there's always going to be this cost
of training, this cost of data generation,
and because we have these nice models we've
developed for many, many decades that came
before neural networks, I think it's important
to keep in mind these models themselves at the
same time as we're developing new methods that are
going to bring in this idea of machine learning.
And the other point here, another thing
to keep in mind is the accuracy point. So
it's not very useful if a neural network
is really fast, but it converges quickly
to the wrong answers. Since this is again,
something really important for scientific
modeling that we want something that
is going to be in a decent ballpark,
that's going to be at least a good initial
guess to getting us to the right solutions.
And then finally, I think this other point,
again, important for scientific modeling is
this idea of reliability and methods.
So a lot of the numerical methods that
have been developed over the decades have
really very strict reliability criteria,
or have been really stress tested to ensure some
level of reliability. And so can we actually
keep that in mind when we're bringing in this
component of machine learning into these problems?
And so I'll start with a really example, common
scenario. And this is really going to be the basis
of the rest of this talk, as I describe some of
the methods that we've been working on now that
go beyond some of these common scenarios or some
of these more toy examples. And in this example,
this is some type of damping pendulum, so
you might have some training data in the
early part of this trajectory, and your
goal is to predict the later dynamics of
this system. And this could be governed by this
very simple PDE. So this is a really toy example.
So if you train a neural network on predicting
only the points in your training data,
so you train it by minimizing this loss
function to match those training data points,
you can see that it doesn't do very well when
it's trying to predict the later time steps, even
though it gets the early time steps that it's seen
before, quite well, which is what we would expect.
But one approach here that I think many of
you will be very, very familiar with is this
idea that you could add that underlying ODE, or
possibly an underlying PDE as a soft constraint
to the neural network loss function, and you
essentially optimize over this so you have that
training data. But then you, since you have some
form of the differential equation, this could be
some type of conservation law, you add that to
the loss function, and you essentially enforce
that over all of the later points in the domain.
And when you train with both of these objectives,
you can see that in this case, it seems like it's
actually fitting the later dynamics, because you
were giving some implicit information, some self
supervisor auxiliary information about the later
time steps. And this is very colloquially known as
this physics informed neural network loss, where
you have these physical laws that are enforced
over points in the domain, so some discretization.
So the one thing about this type of approach,
on one hand, it's potentially a way to deal
with limited data, or if you have some type
of conservation laws you'd like to enforce,
it's potentially one way to try to add in that
type of information. But I think in as maybe many
of you have dealt with if you've trained some
of these models, adding the physical laws this
way doesn't necessarily guarantee the convergence
or correct solution or enforcement of those laws,
and often it takes a lot more beyond that
to actually get some type of convergence
property. And this is just a simple example of a
convection problem where you have just this 1d PD,
as you increase this wave speed parameter,
you can see that this type of training
doesn't converge very well to the later
time steps. So the left hand side is the.
Actual solution in the right hand side is what
would happen when you train the model
and then predict with this solution.
So that brings, yeah, there is a
question on Slide seven. Do you
want to answer that first? Oh, sure,
I actually can't see this screen.
So So what
Pearson asked? What would happen if you
only gave the first data point but then
enforce the PDE constraint? Would
you solve the PDE? Yeah. So if you
only gave this initial condition up here
and then predicted the rest of the PDE,
yeah, yeah. I think it really depends on the
problem setting. I think in a very simple problem
setting like this one, I think that would work
fine if you just gave the initial condition and
then just optimized over the rest of the PD, so
you might not even need those training data points
in the first place. But this setting doesn't do
super well when you go to harder problem settings
if you just do this kind of ad hoc approach. And
so one example here is that in this case, only
the training was done by only giving the initial
condition and the boundary conditions and then
predicting a solution over the rest of the domain.
And as you can see, in this case, especially
when you have very sharp features in your
solution, this becomes a lot harder to capture.
I hope that answered Pearson's
questions. If not Pearson, speak up
or let's move on. Great. Then feel free
to ask questions throughout the talk.
So that brings me to one of the main idea
of this talk, which is really this idea of,
how do we resolve some of these underlying
issues when we try to solve PDS with machine
learning? And there's a few key points
here, I think, to keep in mind. So one
of those points is that this idea of physical
consistency or having an accurate solution,
this is especially important at inference.
So at test time, when we actually want to go
use the neural network for some type of task or
deploy it for some type of task, and the current
approaches that I've mentioned, whether it's data
driven or you add this self supervised PDE loss,
there's no guarantee of those physical laws
being obeyed at test time in particular,
and so that's potentially posing a problem for
how you would actually reliably deploy this.
The other point is that these so far are all grid
based methods, so this means that your solution
is over some type of discretized domain, and that
means that you could have some type of error that
comes up because there's some inherent error in
that discretization. And it can also be expensive,
because, especially if you're training with some
type of PDE loss, it requires differentiating back
through that if you're going to take derivatives,
if you have higher order derivatives than your
loss and if your architecture is more complicated,
that can start to get expensive to train.
And there's also some other points here. So
sometimes, if you have some type of physical law,
and it's only approximately enforced, so the soft
constraint added to the loss function, this can
sometimes be hard to optimize over and tricky to
actually get to converge. And again, you have that
first issue that this type of approach doesn't
guarantee any convergence at test time. And all of
these issues all become particularly noticeable in
limited data settings when you don't have a lot of
data, each of these issues really comes up again
and again and becomes a bigger and bigger problem.
So the general theme of this talk is really going
to be about this idea of numerical methods that
have been really successful historically at
modeling complex systems and machine learning
that's been very fast and successful at these
prediction tasks in a lot of different areas.
How do we take both of these and get the best
of both worlds when we develop the next set of
methods for scientific modeling problems? And both
of these have their limitations too. So numerical
methods can be quite slow. Machine learning can
be hard to get accurate or hard to generalize
to new problems. And so we're hoping that by
taking the best of both worlds, we can also
limit the actual limitations of both of these
approaches, and by combining both, the goal is
perhaps we can get better accuracy with less data,
as well as more robust methods downstream. And so
the approaches that I'll talk about are some
of the things that we've been thinking about
and working on for exploring this intersection
between numerical methods and neural networks.
So the in for most of this talk, the
problem setting that I'll talk about,
is solving PDS that represent.
And some type of complex system. So in this
case, this is an example of navier stokes
equations. You might have some initial
conditions, like an initial vorticity,
and your goal is to predict the spatiotemporal
behavior of the system over time. And in these
cases, because these are spatiotemporal
phenomena or fluid problems that we know
a little bit about. We can sometimes
know that this might have some type
of conservation of momentum, it might have
some type of conservation of mass, and so on.
So the first issue I talked about was this idea
that physical laws are not imposed at test time,
and this can be when it matters most to have
that physical consistency. And this can also be,
sometimes be useful to enforce
these laws at training time,
because that ends up actually improving
convergence. This ends up helping a lot,
especially in limited data settings. And so the
first solution I'll talk about is implementing
PDE constrained optimization as a layer in a
neural network to tackle some of these issues.
So before the neural network setup looked
something like this, where you have some
spatial temporal points in your domain, you
use a neural network to predict the solution,
and you could train to either matching the
solution loss over your domain. You could also
add this differential equation loss for the PDE so
this soft constraint approach, and then to train a
neural network, we would back propagate through
this loss function with respect to the weights
of the neural network. And after we train the
neural network, we can go test it on new problems.
As mentioned before, there are some potential
issues with this approach, and so the thing
that we try to do instead is actually look at,
can we have more control over these physical
laws and enforcing these physical laws? And
to do so, we develop this framework to add
a PD constraint optimization layer to a
neural network architecture. So this is a
high level overview, but I'll go into some of the
important pieces and details. And in this case,
this PDE constrained optimization layer can be
added on top of any neural network architecture.
So the problem setting here is essentially
differential operator learning, where we're trying
to find some operator that maps some parameters
here to some solutions u, such that that
conservation law or that operator is enforced,
and we know that it's going to be equal to
zero. So what we do here is we
take a neural network. So this
is a neural network F, parametrized by some theta,
and we want to map the neural network the
parameters of your physical system to B,
which is a set of n basis functions. So our neural
network is trying to do this parameter mapping,
and we formulate this instead as we want to
find some omega such that when you take this
product of those basis functions with respect
to omega, this is going to satisfy whatever
your conservation law is. So this equivalency is
trying to make an approximation to your solution u
and so what we do is we solve for this
omega value using some type of iterative,
nonlinear least squares solver. So this could be
LM, it could be gauss Newton, or whatever your
favorite solver is. And this is done by sampling
a set of spatiotemporal points on your domain.
And after we solve this problem, the final
solution operator prediction is reconstructed,
together with having solved for a reasonable value
of omega with your numerical solver, and so you're
then having some approximation for the solution
using this approach instead. So this is giving you
a bit more precise control over actually enforcing
this conservation law, because you're explicitly
using a solver to try to actually approximate
that PDE constrained optimization problem.
So when you look at this setting, I went through
essentially what's a forward pass of the neural
network. But the issue is that when you run that
solver, so you project your outputs of the neural
network onto some solver, and that's the solver
that you're running to now actually learn the PDEs
more precisely. The issue is that when you take
all of these steps of your solver, you still have
to train the neural network somehow. And doing
standard backpropagation, where you differentiate
back through all of those steps, is really
expensive. It's actually usually impossible,
because you run out of memory very quickly. And
so to get around this issue, what we did instead
is some so we looked at this problem, and we see
that what we want to do is the solver is run after
the neural network to come to a solution. And
if we want to actually train the neural network,
we need to differentiate back, and we need
to do some type of gradient descent on theta.
Our neural network parameters to
learn what the correct solution
is. And so we use implicit function
theorem and implicit differentiation,
which I think is a really powerful tool when
you're doing anything with combining numerical
methods and neural networks. And what that does
is you can formulate this differentiation problem
in an implicit way. So what that means is that
you don't need to differentiate back through all
the steps of your solver. So you don't have to
back propagate through the whole computational
graph that got you to that final point. You can
just differentiate the last step and bypass all
of those intermediate steps. And a lot of
the details, you can check out the paper for
a lot of the details on the full framework
and the exact problem that you're solving,
but this is essentially the trick that makes it
possible to combine these two things together.
So coming back to this and the full
problem setup. So now we have this
neural network architecture we project onto
this PDE constrained optimization layer,
which solves the optimization problem, more
precisely, that represents our conservation
laws. We use implicit differentiation to train
the model. So what it means is that the forward
pass of the neural network is decoupled from
the backward pass of the neural network, and
that allows us to train this whole thing, end to
end, with both the neural network and the solver,
and this means that the neural network is
able to get direct feedback from the solver,
so the weights can update based on this exact
solve that happens in the PDE constrained
optimization layer. And then at test time, we
can go ahead and run this neural network on a
new problem. And because the forward pass of the
neural network still goes through this layer here,
it means that those constraints are more
precisely enforced at test time as well.
So here's a very simple example of when we first
tried this out. So this was for a Darcy flow
problem, very simple PDE, where you have some PDE
parameters, in this case, diffusion coefficients,
and you want to learn what the PDE solution is.
And so we ran this with a baseline of we just add
the conservation laws to the loss function. This
soft constraint approach, which does, does okay,
but doesn't really converge that well, and it
sort of plateaus at this point. And our new model,
where we implement this new layer, which
is acts more like a hard constraint,
and you can see that it starts at a much
lower point and then continues to go down.
And this is on some unseen test set, so
we just track how well it's doing during
training on this test set. So it does tend to
converge more quickly for a problem like this.
But that being said, I mentioned that during
training, you're going through this new layer
and differentiating it, but also during test
time, you also have to go through that new
layer. And what that means is that as you enforce
this layer and this whole setup on more and more
points which can happen or is quite necessary
when your problem gets quite hard, that also
means that your computational expense and memory
cost increases. So this is an example of solving
the 2d navier stokes equations. So as we increase
the number of sampled points, it's likely that the
model does better, because it's able to solve
for a larger domain and force whatever physical
laws over a larger domain. But the issue is that
as you increase these points, both your training
and your inference time get larger and larger.
So there's this limitation of the computational
trade off. And if you sample more points in this
setup, you often need to have a lower batch size
because of the memory costs, and that ends up
actually hurting training stability. So for
some of these much harder problems, it becomes
very difficult to solve with this current setup.
So to get around that setting, we used a mixture
of experts approach to actually scale this
full architecture, and mixture of experts
really has made it possible to scale a lot
of very large models in many other fields
of machine learning, like NLP and vision,
and it's this nice way of actually increasing
the capacity of the neural network,
but still balancing the computational expense
where now you split the computation over a
bunch of different experts that solve
these different sub domain problems,
and so we wanted to see if we could actually
bring this idea of mixture of experts to our
physical modeling problem and actually be
able to scale it to much harder systems.
So we frame this PDA constrained optimization
problem in our neural network as a mixture of
experts instead. And the main difference
is, before we had this neural network,
this f of theta, and we would go ahead and go
straight to the end here and run our solver,
do our prediction, and this time,
we actually split our our domain.
Into a bunch of different subdomains and use an
expert to solve the problem along each subdomain.
So what that fully looks like is you have
some type of neural network. Here. We use
a neural operator for this type of problem.
It doesn't matter which architecture you use,
though, it could be your favorite one. And
this whole part here is our PE constrained
optimization layer. And to scale it up, we
do this domain decomposition where we have
a bunch of different subdomains, and we enforce
this constrained optimization problem over each
subdomain. So these are the hard constraints
that are enforced over these subdomains by
the different experts. And so this makes those
constraints localized, and it's split across
multiple experts here, so it's not just
one single one, but many different ones.
And the advantage of this is that now
we've actually decomposed our domain,
and we can actually solve this problem
in parallel. So when we put it all
together, if we have some PDE domain, I've
kept it very simple here, just a 2d problem,
but we also do this on 3d and 40 settings. You
can give this PD domain to the neural network,
and it'll go through this whole process of
you have these learnable basis functions here.
You evaluate and partition them over your
sub domains. You have this mixture of expert
setting, where each expert locally solves the
problem. And so it looks something like this,
where within each expert you're still doing that
same task of finding a set of omega that satisfies
this product here and actually satisfies the
PDE of interest. So it's the local constraint
over each subdomain. And then you can go ahead and
reassemble your full predicted solution together,
and then putting it all together, you go ahead
and differentiate your output, and then you use
implicit function theorem to actually train the
full model end to end. And when you do this,
that means that each expert is both being used in
the forward pass, but also in the backwards pass
through this implicit differentiation technique.
So this allows you to actually scale the model and
train it over a lot of different problems, because
everything can also be done in parallel now.
So as an example of what that looks like,
this is, this is a problem, diffusion sorption
problem. It's a tricky problem, actually, because
it has a singularity at a certain point here, and
this is what the numerical solver solution would
look like. And if you're using a soft constraint
approach, because of some of those difficulties,
you can see here that in a lot of cases, it's not
really able to converge to any solution. So when
we use our initial approach where we just have
a hard constraint, we start to do a little bit
better. But I think it's limited to some extent,
because you need to sample a lot of points for
this problem, and because we can't fit all of
those points, we often have to use a lower batch
size, so it actually hurts our training stability.
But when we go ahead and scale this with this new
mixture of experts approach, we get a lot closer
to what the true solution should be, so it starts
to match the numerical solution pretty well.
Another advantage is this idea of lacking
training stability. So when we actually
train with our regular layer, with no mixture
of experts, it's not doing super well because
of the fact that during training it's unstable.
And it's not just because of this limitation
that it can't sample enough points
because of computational expense,
but when you actually then train with this
Moe setting, this is another sample that was
pulled out of the system. So we had a test set
of a few 100 samples. In this case, when you
actually train with that Moe setting, you're
a lot more stable and predictable when you're
doing the training. So it's converging slowly
to the right solution in a more stable way. And
then when we come back to this plot where we saw
that one of the limitations before was that as you
increase the number of points, your training
and inference time gets slower and slower. In
this case, now, when you increase the number of
points, this scale sub linearly. So this is a lot
more efficient. I think this is quite important,
because as we get to the whole point of neural
networks is to be faster than numerical solvers,
and at inference time. In particular, if running a
neural network is slower than running a numerical
solver, there's not really much of an advantage
to the neural network approach. So getting this
down to some level of computational efficiency and
speed, I think, is very important for actually
the whole purpose of using neural networks.
So we'll come back to some of these
underlying issues that we looked at
earlier about resolving solving PDS with
machine learning. And the second issue I
had mentioned was this idea that grid based meth.
Methods introduce errors. So when you solve for a
solution over a discretized domain, that's going
to inherently introduce some errors. And so one
solution that we thought of when we looked at this
problem was, again, an idea of taking spectral
methods, which have been really successful,
used quite well in applied mathematics and
scientific computing, and seeing if we could take
the advantages of spectral methods and combine
that with the advantages of neural networks.
So coming back to this setting of this
physics and form neural network loss,
so this would be like a self supervised setting
for solving PDS. So when you optimize over this PD
residual in the loss function, there's this first
point that you're optimizing over physical points
in your domain. So those grid based methods
introduce errors. It can also require a large
number of sampled points. So if your problem is
hard, you may need a lot of points to optimize
over. And so this approach also just has issues
with scaling to large grid sizes. And finally,
if you're looking at this setting where you're
using a neural operator and then optimizing over
it with some type of PDE loss, this can be
expensive to differentiate back through the
architecture, especially for more complicated
architectures like the Fourier neural operator,
it means that some of the scaling
actually doesn't do super well,
especially if you have higher order
derivatives that you're trying to enforce.
So spectral methods have been very powerful for
solving PDEs. So these basis function expansions,
you could use Chebyshev polynomials. As one
example, you could use la gendre polynomials.
They can be quite powerful and efficient, and
when you're learning PDS in in this spectral
representation, you can really do accurate
approximations of differentiation and integration,
or you can really do accurate approximations of
algebraic operations going out to a certain when
you go out to a certain number of terms when
you do that basis expansion. And so I think
these have a lot of potential to also think about
how they can be integrated with neural networks,
because there are so many advantages of these
methods in the scientific computing setting.
And so to take the ideas from spectral
methods and neural networks and really
get the best of both worlds, we came up with
this neural spectral methods approach where
we have in our base architecture some type of
spectral based neural operator. It's not just
limited to Fourier basis. So you can actually use
Chebyshev polynomials or Legendre polynomials,
so really any spectral basis function, and we
actually find that for a lot of the problems
we look at, using Chebyshev basis actually
works a lot better than a Fourier basis,
particularly in cases where you don't
have periodic boundary conditions,
as what you would expect for when you see how
where they're used in scientific computing.
And we also have this spectral loss function,
and I'll go through each of these. And this is
in contrast this idea of physical space learning
that had some of the limitations mentioned before,
that it could be harder to learn, and
you have these grid size limitations.
So we start, in this case, in our base
architecture by having we have parameters
to solutions. This is the same setting
that we want to learn. And we look at the
spectral representation of our parameters.
We do these spectral transformations. So
this is where we're deciding what basis
functions we want to use, in this case,
Chebyshev polynomials tend to be the
ones that end up working quite well.
And then, for last point, we use
the spectral training procedure
where we can actually use parsevals
identity to come up with an equivalency
between some type of PDE loss in your physical
domain. And what that spectral representation is,
because you can have this equivalency through the
sum of the square of your spectral coefficients,
and that essentially gives you a very good
approximation for what the PE residual of the
problem is. And what that means is that you can
actually not just project to spectral space and do
all of your architecture transformations in this
part of the architecture. You can then train the
whole model fully in spectral space by using this
spectral loss function, and that allows you to
just do everything in the spectral domain, which
will have some advantages, as I'll talk about now.
But just a quick note is that this
is in contrast to training in the
physical domain. If you have some grid based
neural operator and you have this PDE loss,
or this physics informed neural network loss,
so this would be so the top part is the spectral
approach, in contrast to this physical approach.
So here's one example.
Where we looked at a reaction
diffusion system. So in this case,
we have, this is just a 2d problem. You
have some temporal dimension and some
spatial dimension. And we ran a numerical
solver on this so you see that it behaves
very predictably. As you increase the resolution
of your domain, the error gets lower and lower,
and this error is relative to a very fine
discretization. So we generated a really
fine solution, and then we sub sampled it to
represent all of these different grid points.
So if you use this approach of a standard grid
based neural operator, and you add and then you
add some type of PDE loss to that. So this would
be training only in physical space. You can see
that it doesn't quite match up super well, so
it's slower with a finer discretization. And
one thing is that you can see that it actually
overfits a little bit to the training grid that
it was trained on. So it actually sometimes
will do worse for higher training grids,
rather than decrease continuously, like this
standard numerical solver. So this would be
like the grid based approaches. And in contrast,
when you do this all in the spectral domain,
so you use the approach I talked about, where
you have this neural network, you train it
with a spectral loss, you end up down here for
all of your grid sizes, because now the grid
no longer matters, because your computational
cost is constant regardless of the grid size,
because you're naturally not expressing your
loss function in terms of the grid itself. So
there's no sampling issue here, and you can see
that it maintains accuracy. So when you compare
it to the standard numerical solver, it's faster
for the same level of accuracy, which I think is
the comparison that we should be doing for all new
neural net work methods in this ml for PDE space.
We also went and looked at different forms of the
Navier stokes equations. So this is an example
where we're looking at unforced navier stokes
equations, where the top row is our numerical
solver, the middle row is our method, and the
bottom row is when you train only in physical
space. So this is actually an animation, but
we converge pretty quickly with this spectral
approach, whereas when you look at the bottom
row, there's a lot of features here that just
don't converge to what the numerical solver looks
like, and these are somewhat hard to resolve.
And this is another example where now we look at
force navier stokes equations. So we have this
numerical solver we train only in physical
space, and this actually blows up over long
time scales. So the error gets really high as
you get further and further away in time, and
when you do this approach with spectral methods,
it's a lot more well behaved. So over time, the
total relative error ends up being a lot lower.
And I didn't plot the computational speed here,
but that's also a very big advantage of
this approach, that it's a lot faster,
both during training, but also when you
actually go and use this model during inference.
So the last thing I'll talk about is, so far
I've talked about this idea of inspiration
for numerical methods and neural networks in
the context of solving PDS, so fluid dynamics
problems or other general types of PDs. But I
think these simulation in the loop ideas can
also be really relevant for other problems like
molecular systems or things at the atomistic
scale and running molecular dynamics. So this is
an approach here, where the way you train models
for molecular dynamics, a very common approach is
that you try to approximate the potential energy
surface of these systems, and if you have a good
approximation for the energies and the forces,
you can then run these simulations over
time by using Numerical Integrator. And
hopefully you can run it for very long time
scales without it running into instabilities,
because then you can study the system better.
You can compute observables about the system
from that type of simulation. But there
are also some challenges here. So this is
an example of a neural network trained for
these molecular simulators. And we go ahead
and run this over in time, so we simulate
the system over, ideally long time steps.
And initially it seems okay, but
as you simulate the system larger,
longer and longer, you see that there's this
very clear, unphysical thing happening where
there's this bond stretching that results
in a very unstable structure. And both,
what that means is that so you
can't really trust the simulation,
because there are these instabilities coming up.
But any types of properties that you then want to
compute from that simulation are probably
going to be very inaccurate, because the
simulation is just not stable enough to get to
the point of where you can do those computations.
So coming back.
Back to the idea of simulation in the loop,
there's a lot of learning signal that you can get
from the molecular simulation itself. So in this
case, this approach to slightly different problem
setting in that you might have some atomistic
system, some molecular system, you give it to
a neural network, and you predict the energies
and the forces of that system. And once you have
the forces, you can use numerical integration to
get to your next time step. And this is how you
would run the simulation over time. And as you run
this MD simulation over time, and keep running it,
you can compute system observables about
that system, so something about that system,
or multiple properties of that system. And
so typically, the common approach to train
these models is to train this neural network to
adjust the energies and forces. But in this case,
we wanted to actually train the neural network
to the simulation itself. So actually use all of
this information of the simulation and build
that into the training procedure somehow,
because that would also then allow us to train
to more than just energies and forces. We could
actually train to observables of the system.
Maybe those observables come from experiment.
So this could be actually a way to bridge
some type of theory experiment gap as well.
And so the same idea here is when we go
and train to these observables over MD
simulation. So we run the MD simulation, we
query the neural network, run the integrator,
we compute system observables, and we take a loss
function on the observables. Now we come into the
same issue that we had before, where you can't
differentiate back through all of the steps of
your MD simulation, because it means that you're
going to differentiate through all of the steps
of your Numerical Integrator. And so instead,
here we can do the same thing. We can train the
neural network with implicit differentiation. So
there's actually a way. It's a different approach
to formulate this implicit differentiation
problem than the previous approach I talked
about, because this is actually a stochastic
setting, so you're actually doing implicit
differentiation over a distribution. But
the key idea here is that you can formulate,
taking the gradients this way. And the
key insight is really that you separate,
getting the out the neural network output
from the rest of the neural network itself,
so you don't have to back, propagate back through
all of the steps of the solver to get there.
And so this ends up also being quite powerful in
the context of molecular dynamics. So this is an
example of a water system, and there's a local
instability that comes up. So the full simulation
in the loop method and the differentiation
technique, we call this Boltzmann estimator,
because we formulate the implicit differentiation
problem based on the fact that we know that the
underlying system obeys a Boltzmann distribution.
And this is how you can actually formulate what
the differentiation task should be. And so
before training, when you use standard training,
so the approach over here, where you just
train it with these energies and forces.
When you run this system over time, over all of
these picoseconds, all of the trajectories become
unstable relatively quickly, so often too quickly
before you can actually compute things that are of
interest, so observables of interest about the
system. But when you actually now train it in
this simulation, in the loop style, after we do
our training procedure, we can actually simulate
this system for we went although we went up to one
nanosecond, but you can also go further than that,
then you can see that the system no longer
has the same instability problems as before.
And the way that this nicely manifests is that
if we then want to go and actually compute things
from the system. So in this case, we don't train
it on anything about the diffusivity coefficient,
so it doesn't see anything about this.
But after we train it with this procedure,
and we go run it at test time, and we compute
the diffusivity coefficient of the system,
we end up being a lot closer to what the true
coefficient is. So this black line here represents
the reference. And before training, all of these
before our training, the trajectories were not
really getting any close to those reference
observables. And after our training, we're a lot
more in the ballpark or in the general range of
what that true diffusivity coefficient should be.
And so I think this type of procedure is powerful
for both bridging this theory and experiment gap,
but also the fact that by doing this procedure,
you can improve both the stability and performance
on new systems or new observables, and actually
have some level of hopefully more reliability in
running those molecular simulations downstream.
And the very high level general idea of reading
numerical simulations with neural networks is
still generally true here in this setting as well.
So in summary, I think.
Think neural networks do have a lot of
potential for these physical modeling problems,
but at the same time, we really need to keep in
mind this idea that we need accurate and rigorous
methods that are going to be able to give us
reliable, physically consistent answers when
we go run that method in a simulation, or
go run that neural network in a simulation,
and this idea of also having trust during
deployment. So after we train a model,
we would like to trust it when we actually go use
it for a lot of different downstream tasks. And
so here I talked about a few different examples
of the best of both worlds. So taking numerical
methods and deep learning and putting these
together with this idea of differentiable solvers,
so ways to actually come up with differentiation
techniques that let you train these two things
together. So whether that's through this idea of
a PDE constrained optimization layer in the neural
network, or taking neural networks and combining
them with spectral methods, ideas, as well as the
fact that these simulation in the loop. Ideas also
extend to problems like molecular dynamics, where
it's a bit of a different setting because you have
a stochastic setting, but you can still formulate
the same differentiation approaches and train this
model to the output of a simulation itself, and
ideally improve the simulation stability as well
as the accuracy of the properties that you compute
from that simulation. And the papers with all the
code available for everything I talked about are
all down here, so you can definitely go check it
out and let us know if you have any questions.
And finally, I'd like to thank a lot of
the great students that I get to work
with. So a lot of the work I talked about
here was with yihang Nitin and Sanjeev on
all of these different areas. And I'll go
ahead and come back to this summary slide,
and happy to take any more questions as
well. Thanks, awesome, awesome. Thank
thank you so much for the wonderful talk.
Very nice. Okay, there there were questions
during your talk. So the first
question is by GI Joe. She wants
to know about what kind of neural network
you used in Slide eight. Oh, sure, yeah.
I think that's when you talk about the pins.
Oh, yeah. I think slide eight, yeah,
that was just the toy example setting
in. In that setting, it was just a simple
MLP for that problem. But in some of the
later methods settings I showed, we used a few
different types of neural operator architectures,
but the methods I was talking about, a lot of them
are agnostic to the underlying architecture. But
in in that toy example, it was just a just
a regular, fully connected neural network.
And second question is by Betty in slide 45 and 46
how would the spectral methods work when the
flow has discontinuities? For example? Yeah,
that's a really good question. So how would you
solve a problem if there's any discontinuities?
That's actually exactly what we're working on
right now. So we have some ideas that there are
potentially ways that you could parameterize
your domain with maybe like using something
analogous to finite element methods, and that
would at least help with the fact that you would
have discontinuities in your domain. I think
it's a really good and very important problem,
especially if you're looking at systems
with complex or varying geometries.
Okay. Next question is by Sakhar.
He has a bunch of questions.
Do you mind Sakhar? Unmute
yourself and then ask that question yourself. I
If not, I can ask, okay, his first question
is, is there a reference for implicit different
differentiation applied to these applications,
the neural net, plus the numerical solver? That's
his first question, yeah, for these areas.
So some of the earlier work in this area,
there was this idea of OPT net or optimization
as a layer, which was this very general approach
that maybe you could incorporate some type
of optimization problem into neural networks.
And there's also been approaches like using the
adjoint method, though, that's not, I think, quite
in the same flavor as a lot of the work that I
talked about here. And the adjoint method actually
can have numerical instability problems that don't
come up in the same way for in the settings that I
talked about here, for, in the context of
using implicit differentiation for, for.
Example solving PDE problems. I think
the reference would really be like some
of our work here, where we in this first
paper, we actually formulated doing this
as a PDE constraint optimization problem
and then extended it to the MOE setting.
Okay. And his second question is, can the
computation by each expert in the MOE method be
parallel? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. It can definitely
be parallelized. So that's one of the big
advantages, that you're not just splitting solving
the problem on a bunch of different subdomains,
but you can do that computation on the
all of those subdomains in parallel. So
that's also one of the reasons there's a big
speed up in doing it with the MOE setting.
Okay, the last question by Sakhar is, how much
faster, slower is the method Moe compared to a
numerical solver for inference, yeah, compared to
a numerical solver for inference for the settings
that we looked at. So we started looking at a
few different settings, diffusion, sorption,
reaction, diffusion problems, navier stokes
problems. With the MOE setting, we are faster
than a numerical solver. In the original setting
that we had, where we didn't use the MOE, we were
about equal with a numerical solver at the
time. So the MOE was actually quite crucial
to being faster. That being said, when we first
did this there actually wasn't super optimized
to run these iterative solvers on GPUs. That
operation was actually not super well optimized
for the in this context of actually trying to
do optimization directly there, because you
have to do it on the GPUs if you want to train it
with a neural network. Since then, there's been
a lot of improvements. So I think actually,
at this point, even without the MOE setting,
I think we actually would be faster than a the
numerical solver for a lot of problems, but you
get a much bigger speed up. And the more practical
version of this is to do it in the MOE setting.
Okay. Next question is by Mike, is there
a communication in the parallel solve at
the domain boundaries? Yeah, that's a really
good question. So how do you deal with the
fact that there's a domain decomposition and
there could be issues between the boundaries?
So what we actually found there was that as
long as each expert so each sub domain solve,
had the global initial and boundary conditions,
that was actually enough for it to learn something
reasonable and not have issues at the boundaries.
Before we gave those global conditions,
we were doing some things like trying
to actually have overlapping domains,
like stitching the boundary conditions, doing
some type of Gaussian smoothing over the boundary
conditions, or over the boundary conditions
of the different domains, but just giving the
global initial and boundary conditions to each
subdomain ended up actually solving that issue.
Okay. Next question is by Quan Chong,
nice talk. You've shown strong advantage
of neural spectral method. Perhaps
he missed it. But are there any deficiencies to
the methods? Yeah, so for deficient deficiencies
for the methods. So I think one was the point
that was brought up earlier, how do you deal with
discontinuities? And so this is something that
we're like I mentioned. We're actively working
on this and using approaches to actually deal
directly with discontinuities, especially if you
have very complex domain geometries and the so
that's one approach. The other approach is also
that sometimes you might need more frequency
modes to actually really capture the domain,
especially for some of these more complex
problems. And so you have to be careful there,
because there's that trade off of more modes means
that you have some computational inefficiencies.
So it's going to be slower to train the model
or run the model. But that's also something
that we're actively working on now, and actually
we've already made some speed ups which will be
pushed to this repository pretty soon, that deal
with that computational inefficiency problem.
All right. Quan Chen also asked, also, can
you recommend a good reference paper on Moe
theory? Yeah, for a good reference paper.
So the one of the earlier papers, I think,
with Noam shazier from 2017 that's a good
starting point for one of the earlier examples
of something that worked quite well. But if
you want to go even further to the theory,
there's papers from the 90s that
describe the problem setting,
but that 2017 paper is an example of showing
it in action in large scale machine learning.
Okay.
Next question is by Mike, if you run the new
approaches, can you show that
you can run these problems?
Out indefinitely without an instability,
yes. So is that in the PDE setting, or
like the molecular dynamics setting?
Probably PDE setting, I'm sure.
Yeah. PDE, yes, sure, yeah. So,
so we haven't tried running it out indefinitely,
so to speak, just running it for months and months
at a time. I think this does definitely help
stabilize the methods, so you are able to do
these much longer rollouts. And this is actually
something we've started testing a lot more now,
so we are able to run some of these navier stokes
systems for longer time scales. But I think this
also comes into as a problem becomes harder
and harder. So if you have turbulence flow,
for example, you have really high Reynolds
numbers, I think that's where long time scales
becomes hard. And I think that's actually one
of the big challenges that we should really be
working on with these methods to see how well
we can do that, that long time scale modeling.
Okay, next question is by Xu Tong,
does the network approximate the coefficients of
the basis function for the spectral method? If so,
will there be an error when transforming the
field from the physical domain to the spectral
domain? Will this error propagate
during the time domain evolution.
So sounds like the question is, so you have,
you're operating on spectral coefficients,
and you're training specifically in spectral
space on those coefficients. So the nice
thing about the spectral approach,
and I can go back here, so this,
this identity here. So parcel of its identity
essentially gives you an exact form of the
PDE residual, up to a certain amount of basis
functions. So whatever you truncate your basis
functions at, and so by actually. And so this is
computed directly with the sum of the squares of
your spectral coefficients. And so because you
can actually do this as an exact computation,
this actually ends up not really mattering that
much, because you've effectively solved for the
PE residual in a mostly exact way, up to a
certain level of basis function expansions.
And so that issue doesn't really or we found that
that issue doesn't really come up when we actually
use this neural spectral methods approach on a
on a physical problem, that when you actually
translate this to solving on a physical
grid, it ends up being the same either way,
right?
You know, related question by me, but it
is that accuracy of the spectral method,
neural spectral method is bounded by
the whatever the spectral you know the
basis you you are using, right? I mean, if
the spectral basis can capture like 99.9%
of your solutions, then you are stuck
with it. That's the best you can do,
right? So it's so it is, so it is. It does
depend on what spectral basis set that you use,
but we're also exploiting the fact that as
your basis expansion goes towards infinity,
it means that you're, in theory, going to
be able to exactly approximate the solution.
Yeah, in theory, yes. But in practice,
you have to truncate at some point. You
cannot go infinity. So there will be,
you know, the limitation in accuracy,
how much you can represent with the Yeah. So we,
so we found, at least in the settings I showed,
and we're now testing it on harder settings that
there was, we didn't have to go towards infinity
or something, to a very, very large number of
terms. Usually we could go within a reasonable
amount, within a reasonable computation
cost, and get most of the way there. If,
if the if there is no shock or discontinuity, yeah
in the solution, yes, right, exactly, if there's
no shocker discontinuity, and that area now we're
actively working on with a few other approaches.
Another question by me is, you know,
nonlinear manifold reduced to the model, like a
projection based reduced model, but you introduced
that nonlinear manifold you know, the neural
network, kind of basis social representations,
and you plug that into the you know, existing
numerical method and solve for the latent space
coefficients instead of the full space you
know, so that you know, you get The efficiency
the the the method you, you know,
introduce, so called the physics constraint
methods you know, the first method you introduced,
it has a very similarity between
those two, by the fact that you,
you do, take advantage of the
existing numerical method and in.
Instead of the traditional basis,
you use the neural network basis,
and then you actually solve that. PDE, right?
So, yeah, so do are you? So my first question
is, are you familiar with that nonlinear
manifold with the student model? Yeah, I'm
a bit I'm familiar with that general area,
and I do agree that I think there is some overlap
in that. I think some of the advantages of both
the approaches I talked about here and that
approach are that you're doing a change of basis
and potentially now learning in a space that's
going to be easier to learn on than it was before.
Yeah, so, but in that project, I'm
basically some of the, you know,
because you're introducing more nonlinearity
through the neural network you just introduced,
which was not there before. So, so the
complexity of the nonlinearity is has increased.
So because of that, it is very important
to, you know, apply the technique,
so called hyper productions there,
otherwise you wouldn't get the speed up,
because it's you're interacting
with the existing numerical methods,
and you have increased the non linearity in very
intertwined way. So you do need some special
method to deal with it. I'm wondering if, for
your method, if you need those kind of you know,
how do you handle the nonlinearity you
introduce through that neural network? Yeah,
so I think in practice, we haven't seen that be
a big issue. At one point we were using much more
complicated iterative solvers, because we thought
that that would be the one to one between solving
this in a numerical setting and solving this in
the neural network setting. But as long as we just
have a reasonable iterative, nonlinear, least
square Solver, we found that the neural network
would do the rest of the heavy lifting,
and so we didn't explicitly see, I think,
this issue that you're describing, but I think
it's definitely interesting, and it would be
worth testing out on more cases to see if this
actually explicitly needs to be dealt with.
All right, well,
it's three minutes after 11, so I think
it's a good time to finish our, you know,
your seminar. Thank you so
much for the wonderful talk
and beautiful introduction of those
three methods. And, yeah, definitely
more interested in going too deep and then
learn more about it. So thank you so much.
Yeah, thanks a lot for all of the great questions.
It was fun to have so many questions,
and feel free to contact me afterwards
if you want to talk more or have more
questions. Awesome, thank you, Aditi,
great. Thanks.